in europe there's a major effort to
avert a nuclear calamity as well as to
prevent a crippling energy shortage for
millions of people a russian power
supplier has scrapped today's deadline
to resume delivering natural gas to
germany through a key pipeline at the
same time russia and ukraine continue to
blame each other for more shelling near
europe's largest nuclear plant the plan
has become a major factor on the front
line of the war deborah patta is in kiev
the ukrainian capital
deborah good morning
good morning six nuclear inspectors
remain at the zaparija power plant this
weekend then the team goes down to two
international atomic energy agents who
will stay there permanently director
general rafael gracie plans to release a
report on the safety of the plant early
this coming week
for a third day atomic energy inspectors
will work at the plant to avert a
nuclear disaster
but finally being there is like the
difference between night and day said
team leader rafael grassi who's seen the
impact of constant shelling up close the
physical integrity of the facility
has been violated not once but
several
several times
the zafaria nuclear power plant is
occupied by russian forces but is still
run by ukrainian technicians operating
under extreme duress
one of the biggest concerns remains
damage to power supply lines a constant
electricity supply is essential for
cooling down spent nuclear fuel if they
cannot work this can lead to a major
accident the
military activity and operations are
increasing
in that part
of the country
and this worries me a lot
it is also of deep concern to those
living in the towns next to the power
plant
we're not scared of shellings and
explosions cesarean
it's the thought of something happening
at the power plant that's terrifying
the plant sits on a section of a long
front line that stretches from the
eastern donbass to hebson in the south
where ukraine's much talked up
counter-offensive has intensified
ukraine says the counter offensive could
be a turning point in the war but
details are scarce both sides have
already claimed early successes in the
battle for cbs saturday morning deborah
padda kiev